so we're sitting here with us whole slab
senior vice-president of infrastructure
here at Google Earth could you briefly
describe your role here at Google and
why Google has all of these data centers
I am responsible for technical
infrastructure at Google and that's the
team that builds all the data centers
network servers software systems that
runs our internal cloud and we built
that a long time ago for our own needs
we have very large scale applications
and so we needed a very capable cloud
and now we're making that cloud
available to everyone through App Engine
compute engine and our cloud platform
overall Earths
so what excites you about Google cloud
platform and App Engine in particular
which is the focus of this course what's
great about the Google cloud platform is
is really one that we can make our great
internal infrastructure accessible to
every developer out there and then in
the cloud platform App Engine is really
the one system that makes it really easy
for you to start very small and then
scale to a very large user base so that
if you have a game that suddenly becomes
popular our back-end and our front-end
is going to scale with you and you don't
really have to change your application
very much and that's rare to see an
infrastructure you usually have to do
the hard work up front and with App
Engine you kind of don't really have to
do the hard work at all because we can
do it for you